[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فوضى
روتين
وحده ملحات متناقض ومزعجه وبتوقع انها
مخيفه نوعا ما لكثير منكم
عاشوها لو طلبت منك انك تختار واحده من
هذه الكلمات حتى تبدا فيها حياتك القادمه
شو راح تختار اتاكدوا انه قبل ما تختاروا
انه هذه الكلمه اللي راح تبدا فيها
قصتك اما قصه مدمن المخدرات والمتشرد في
الشوارع الذي لا يذكر عدد المرات التي
اعتقل فيها بسبب
الادمان خليل رفاتي لحسن حظه انه في المره
الاخيره التي حاول الانتحار اعتقل وقرر
انه يتجه الى مراكز تاهيل
للمدمنين اثناء وجوده في هذه المراكز بدا
يشعر بالملل والفراغ فبدا يتدارك وضعه انه
شو ممكن يعمل لحتى يملي هذا الفراغ ففكر
انه يصنع عصير خاص فيه يساعد المرضى ويخفف
عنهم في حالات الخطره والانسحاب من
الادمان
وفعلا بعد اربع اشهر من الالتزام والاصرار
شفي تماما من
الادمان خليل رفاتي الان من اثرياء العالم
يمتلك شركه عصائر تقدر قيمه مبيعاتها
باكثر من 10 ملايين
دولار من النوم متشرد في الشوارع الى
الاسترخاء في طائرته
الخاصه في
الفوضه تكمن
الفرصه عجيب دقه ربط الفوضه
والفرصه لما تلاقي نفسك ضاي
متشائم ما في شيء بينجح معك بالحياه متردد
حيره اضطرابات
بالنوم بتشعر انه حياتك بلا هدف بلا معنى
بلا
نتيجه وما احكي لكم عن التقلبات المزاجيه
اكيد انتم
بتعرفوها اتاكد وقتها انك انت في حاله
فوضى وهذا اول شيء ادركه خليل الفوضه لما
نعترف وجودها بحياتنا بنبدا نبحث لها عن
حل ادراك الفوضه هو اهم شيء وجزء في في
بدايه
تحولك راح احكي لكم شويه معلومات عن
الفوضى ممكن انها
تفاجئ بتعرفوا انه في العلوم تدرس الفوضى
لفهم النظم المعقده
تدرس اما الفن فيستخدمها الفن
للتعبير عن
افكارهم مشاعرهم وحتى
تاملات لو جينا وسالنا شخص غير مدرك وما
بيعرف انه في حاله فوضى لو سالناه شو هدفك
بهاي الحياه شو بتتوقعوا انه
يجاوب اكيد ما راح يعرف يجاوب واذا جاوب
راح يكون جوابه مليان تشاؤم وسلبي
تام فبت بدا انت تحمل مسؤوليه وهم انك
تطلعه من ها الحاله اللي هو فيها وبتقتل
عليه طب ليه ما تطلع معانا ليه ما تروح
على النادي تتمرن او بما انك قاعد اقرا
كتاب جديد تعلم مهاره تستفيد منها المهم
انك تقوم تتحرك ما تضلك قاعد مكانك وبتبدا
تبحث له عن ملاذ امن لحتى تنقذه من الفوضه
اللي هو فيها
فبتو لاول م سا حقيقيه للنجاه من
الفوضى
الروتين مستغرب انه الروتين هو الحل
وبتتقدم انه الروتين هو التكرار
والملل بتعرف شو يعني يكون عندك
روتين بعالم مليان فوضه
وضياع كلنا بنذكر جائحه كورونا صحيح الله
لا يعيدها ونتذكر كيف سلبت اصغر الامور
الروتينيه اللي صرنا نتمنى لو يوم روتيني
واحد يرجع من منبه الصبح اللي برن وبصحي
وينكد علينا لزحمه الشوارع لوجوه الناس
ولا فنجان القهوه اللي مع اصحابك اللي صار
حلم كثير بعيد انه يتحقق لو يوم يرجع عشان
اروح على النادي اللي كنت اضل اجله واحس
انه حمل وعبق كثير كبير علي الروتين مو
انك تكرر الانشطه يوم الاحد اثنين ثلاثاء
اربعاء بشكل ممل الروتين هو
الانضباط
الاستمراريه النظام في
حياتك لما تشعروا بالملل شو اول شي
بتعملوا طبعا بعد ما نبدا نتاف بحكي كلمه
كلنا
بنحكيها جمله باعتقادنا انها هي سحريه بدي
اكسر
الروتين وباعتقاد اذا كسرت الروتين حياتك
راح ترجع ورديه وكلها حماس وطاقه ولا كانه
في شيء وانت ببساطه مو محتاج انك تكسر
روتينك انت ببساطه محتاج تغير وتجدد من
روتينك مو انك
تكسره في فرق كثير كبير بين الروتين
والملل اللي انت بتعيشه لا تخلوا الرو
الشماعه اللي بتعلقوا عليها عدم انتظام
وانضباط في
الحياه خليني اقرب لكم اياها
اكثر مين منكم مر عليه شخص ناجح بالحياه
ودائما بحقق اهدافه ودائما بنطلع عليه
بنتمنى لو نصير مثل هذا الشخص كلنا مر
علينا تقريبا هذا الشخص اللي بنتمنى نكون
مثله طيب شو رايكم انا وياك
نحلل ونرجع لاصل هذا
التمني انت بتتمنى انه يكون عندك روتين
ثابت لحتى تلتزم وتوصل وتحقق
اهدافك مره ثانيه انت عم تتمنى يكون عندك
روتين ثابت تلتزم فيه عشان تحقق
اهدافك الروتين هو اساس الانضباط هو القوه
الكامنه لكن بدي اكون صريحه معكم
شوي شايفين ها
القوه وبرغم
وجودها الا انه للاسف ممكن انها تتاثر
بعوامل
خارجيه تهزها تحركها
تكسرها الى الان انت ما وصلت للامان
الحقيقي كثير بنشوف اشخاص بيلتز بروتين
وصيروا ثابتين وبيروحوا على النادي وبيقرا
كتاب وبينج فجاه بتلاقوا الشخص رجع للفوضى
اللي هو كان
فيها
الروتين ان لم يدعم بوحده داخليه متينه
يتحرك
وحده
سمعتوا نعم هي الوحده نفسها اللي بنعرفها
وحده تطوير ذاتك التركيز على نفسك على
اهدافك على نجاحك مو وحده العزله
والاكتئاب والحزن هي الوحده اللي سميناها
الفوضى لما تشعر بهذ المشاعر انت في حاله
فوضى لازم هي حاله الفوضى تروح لروتين
ثابت هذا الروتين الثابت حتى يضل ثابت
واساس قوي يدعم بوحده
قويه في مقوله بتحكي
في
الوحده نصبح اكثر صدقا مع
انفسنا سمعتوا اكيد بمؤلفه سلسله هاري
بوتر وقصتها اللي كل دور النشر رفض
روايتها لاقت صعوبات وواجهت تحديات لحتى
وصلت للنجاح اللي هي فيه الان
باعتقادكم شو كان اهم سبب في
نجاحها
الوحده ابتعدت
واعتزلت كل شيء ركزت على نفسها ركزت على
روايتها ورجعت بشكل اقوى ورجعت باقوى
النجاحات الى يومنا هذا ركز على نفسك حسن
من نفسك واخلق افضل صوره من نفسك هذه مو
مجرد كلمات انا بحكي لكم اياها اليوم عشان
بدي اخلص الخطاب
هذه خطه عمل تحفظها وتنفذها في وحدتك ركز
على نفسك حسن من نفسك واخلق افضل صوره من
نفسك واصنع
الفرص الفرص موجوده بكل
مكان الفرص ممكن تكون بشخص بتلقيه بفيديو
بتضره برساله بتوصلك بمقوله بتقراها
بسبب مقوله ببدايه مشواري قراتها غيرت
مجرى حياتي خلتني لما كنت ابحث واقرا
والاقي اشخاص ناجحين بخطوات كثير كبيره
عني خلت عندي قناعه انه اي انسان بالدنيا
قدر يحقق اي شي ووصل انا بقدر وانت كمان
بتقدر لكن
بشروط لازم يكون
يهمك يهمك هذا الهدف
والنجاح تتعلم كيف
تحققه وتبدا تنفذه وتلتزم فيه لا تخليه
حبيس
افكارك
ونصيحه لا تتركوا احلامكم بنص الطريق
لانكم تعبتوا وتروحوا تعيشوا احلام غيركم
وتحققوا اهداف
غيركم من واقع تجربه بحكي لكم اياها لا
حدا م انك تحقق احلامك ولا انك تعيش هدفك
ولا انه ينزل لك وزنك او يدرس ويجتهد عنك
ما حدا
بيهمه انت
الوحيد اللي قادر انك تصنع هذا
الشيء ما تضل عايش جو العائل اللي محتاج
اب قيول له قوم ومعلم يقول له ادرس وصاحب
شغل يوقف على راسه على شان يشتغل
انت مسؤول عن نفسك اوجد ذاتك في هذه
الحياه لا ترحل الا وانت راضي عن
نفسك لا تعيش جو محور الكون اللي لازم
الكل يهتم فيه ما حدا فاضي لك الكل مشغول
يحقق اهدافه
ونجاحاته الوحده اللي انا بطلبها منكم
ابدا مو عقاب ويا اخي لو كانت عقاب عاقب
نفسك لو مره شهر سنه ركز على نفسك طور من
نفسك وشوف النتيجه واذا ما عجبتك النتيجه
ارجع للفوضى اللي كنت فيها وال والروتين
عمره ما كان ملل لا تخلوا ها الافكار
تترسخ براسنا ونتا فيها ونصير نرددها بدون
ما نشعر بتاثر على حياتنا وبتاثر على
اسلوب
حياتنا بالعكس هي فرص لحتى تركز على اكثر
شيء مهم بالحياه
بحياتك
انت انت
الوحيد اللي قادر انك تصنع يومك
ومستقبلك واسمعوني شوي
عادي عادي كثير انك تعيش بحاله
فوضى وتخبط وضياع عادي عادي لكن بتعرف شو
لمعادي انك ما تبحث وتلاقي
نفسك نحن هنا خلقنا لكي نضع بصمتنا في هذا
الكون والا ما فائده مجيئنا الي هذه
المقوله قراتها وغيرت مجرى حياتي وكانت
سبب اني اكون في المكان اللي انا فيه الان
وتذكروا دائما معادله كثير مهمه
تذكروها
روتين زائد وحده يساوي
توازن اذا ادركنا
الفوضى وهلا بدي اعيد سؤالي اللي سالته
بالاول لكن هالمره اكيد بنظرت الجديده
وبمعدات
الجديده شو الكلمه اللي رح تختارها لحتى
تب فيها قصتك
القادمه
فوضه
روتين وحده وشكرا
لكم